congratulations on Benjamin Thank You
Benjamin Allen : yeah very very exciting
thank you and let me tell you something
I said this kid would be the best thing
for you you ended up on People magazine
within two days now that I mean he's
great
this was the reasons of course I don't
care about those really know how
important to cover is let's be clear I
mean the baby went right which soon as
you got the baby in your arms right
right to the photo shoot from the
hospital I don't know what I don't like
celebrities who protect oh I have to
hide the baby you know right on the
cover but when they asked I thought why
would I do that I said my friend I go
does it look like I'm promoting my baby
I think it's good for the gays you're
the top gay right it's good to tell your
story this is a unconventional thing
that you did you had a baby on your own
right uh and so I actually then was like
you know what this is a positive
opportunity for me to kind of tell my
story didn't you already get him in oh
my dog has been stickam account it's
just a whole new Andy Cohen I'm looking
at in the sense that have you gotten
high since you got the no I have not
look at you now I haven't I'm not gonna
feel comfortable I want to be super yeah
it's not the time for that do you know
how to handle a baby in this I'm
learning go to class no I did not go to
class it's pretty you can kind of figure
it out you'd had a baby I have a baby
nurse but she's teaching me everything
do you change diapers yeah really yeah
really yeah okay take it easy yeah
that's a really messy one I mean I don't
love the poop on the balls you were in
the delivery room I was and you cut the
umbilical cord so you did you did the
whole thing were you involved with this
person all through the pregnancy this
was a surrogate who carried my child and
I was involved with her yes yeah I heard
a rumor I know it's true yeah that uh
when when you when the surrogate was
giving birth uh-huh what have you
you were laying on the table huh they
put her on top of you yes so you could
feel like you were that's right she was
of Andi and it must be a whole saga
finding a woman who you want to give and
trust yeah cuz you want a nice-looking
woman yeah yeah and you wanna try for as
good as you can get yeah absolutely you
want someone who's you know fairly
intelligence true she's yeah it's a
whole thing right it's a megillah' dude
will you write a book about it you know
it's funny I started writing a book
while this process was going I went to
give my sperm and I was like oh my god
this is the funniest story about how
they put you in the room and the whole
thing where'd you jerk off and I said
well and that's a funny story and I
started to write it all down and then I
was like you know what there's a human
being that you're hating back that's
gonna read this you can't do this did
usually scrapped ice cream bar yeah I
like I can't I can't do that you have a
line I will tell you off the air what I
jerked off to it's very funny I like
that you have a line you're saying hey
this is a person but one day your son
might come to you and say dad you know
I'm old enough now what were you
watching when you conceived me well if
he has the sense of humor that I hope
you imbue in him will do then we will
have that conversation I'm sure I'm
gonna let him ask me did you have an
immediate connection I think you know
I've talked to a lot of moms about this
I did but I think what I'm going through
now is I'm in the process of falling and
we're falling in love with each other
and getting to know each other doesn't
happen instantly doesn't happen
instantly of course yeah